formé à examiner au cas par cas leur
situation emmanuelle béart bonsoir vous
êtes beaucoup investi dans ce mouvement
des sans-papiers de saint bernard en
partageant des jours et des nuits avec
eux et en vivant cette cette opération
d'évacuation jusqu'à la fin ce matin
ce soir vous êtes vous êtes déçu vous
voyez choqué en voyant ces images
d'abord je voudrais dire que je ne suis
pas là en tant que comédienne mais en
tant que femme mère de deux enfants et
j'ai l'impression j'ai le sentiment que
si je ne témoigne pas de ce que j'ai vu
ce matin je ne pourrai plus ni vivres ni
dormir en paix voilà je suis là pour ça
parce que nous avons montré ce que vous
avez montré à la télé je dirais que
c'est peut-être bien loin de là de la
souffrance de tous les enfants avec qui
je suis resté jusqu'au bout avec qui
nous sommes restés jusqu'au bout
je voudrais aussi ajouter que sur
certaines images on ne voit pas qu'il y
a eu plusieurs viols notamment une
église dont les portes ont été détruites
à coups de hache des vitraux cassés des
enfants moi pour ma part j'avais un
petit enfant parce que les enfants
s'accrocher à nous en essayant de
comprendre dans une sorte de terreur des
larmes de créer un petit enfant sur mes
genoux qui a fait pipi tellement il
avait peur qu'ils retrouvent et ni son
père ni sa mère
tout ça pour vous dire que j'ai j'ai
beaucoup de mal à parler parce que c'est
encore très récent et de revoir toffifee
match ce soir c'est très difficile pour
moi
cette opération très violente plus part
je dirais mon ralliement moralement
extrêmement violente on a pour moi
violer la dignité ces gens ces gens ont
été raquer airs et d'endroits d'église
en gymnase pendant des mois et des mois
je ne comprends pas pourquoi on a laissé
pourrir la situation si il fallait
étudier au cas par cas au cas par cas
pourquoi ne l'at-on pas fait avant
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a laissé ses
enfants ces femmes ces hommes
célibataires ces grévistes de la faim
aller aussi loin
je suis indigné révolté mais j'ai
surtout moi j'ai surtout mal pas pour
moi qui ai été arrêté pendant deux
heures au commissariat et qui ont été
relâchés extrêmement vite mais je pense
à ce soir voilà donc de les revoir on a
tous dans la mesure où les sans papiers
ne n'ai pas voulu y l'air de vouloir
accepter une négociation cas parker noah
hier soir j'étais dans l'église on a
pendant cinq mois ces gens ont demandé à
être entendus
on la refuse absolument tout dialogue le
gouvernement
je tiens à préciser que je ne suis
d'aucun parti politique
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à mettre
votre image autres personnalités j'ai
débarqué un jour j'ai débarqué il ya
quelques temps tout simplement par
solidarité humaine avec des couches du
lait je suis moi-même mère de deux
enfants j'ai eu l'impression qu'il était
important d'y aller et d'aider je savais
que les familles commencent à manquer de
produits base des choses essentielles et
donc j'ai débarqué là comme ça et puis
je suis resté parce que j'ai eu un
sentiment d'injustice
on a répété pendant des mois qu'il
s'agissait de clandestins j'ai donc
appris en venant et en parlant avec tous
les gens qui étaient autour de moi les
délégués africains qu'il savait il
s'agissait de gens me en crédits en
clandestinité par les lois parce que
c'est à dire que je n'ai rencontré que
des gens qui ont travaillé en france qui
ont une famille ou qui sont célibataires
mais les stigmates r c'est pas parce
qu'on s'est pas reproduit qu'on n'a pas
le droit qu'on n'a pas le même droit que
les autres
je n'ai rencontré que des gens qui ont
essayé de former une famille de forme et
de ceux de vivre ici où la vie est dure
mais possible dans leur pays on souffre
moi je viens de mauritanie les gens
crèvent là bas au mali les gens crèvent
aussi je peux vous dire c'est chez vous
espériez une autre attitude une autre
issue à ce une autre attitude du
gouvernement ce que j'ai vu ce matin je
ne l'oublierai jamais mais c'est pas
très grave
ce que les enfants ont vu ce matin ils
n'oublieront l'on puisse c'est très
grave ils n'enverront pas non plus ces
traîtres
merci en tout cas des lots d'avoir bien
voulu nous apporter votre témoignage ce
soir l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre à l'église saint bernard est
uniquement condamné à gauche